Mario the man behind the magical taco
truck with riots at her studio every day
gave me a slice of the hottest pepper in
the world scorpion pepper corn - Sam is
heavy the second hottest pepper in the
world it's the second hottest give the
Carolina Reapers the ones I'm going to
chop into little bits we're all gonna
have some any want some Sam wants them I
want some what you do is you like rub it
and then rub your eyes yeah I'm down now
you gotta like chew it up right is that
the agreement chew it up I'm truing it
still my mouth all right still chewing
it all right it's incredibly spicy yeah
my whole mouth smell it poof it's super
super super light of it tasty gosh I'm
so happy you don't have like a whole
pepper it's actually really good friends
best friend come on why did I get a big
piece
Oh God copper makes cooking worse I got
it my nose okay how did he get into his
nose
avocado didn't want to get in your eyes
oh my god
I wouldn't that holy crap a week or two
ago I posted a clip on the corridor
digital Instagram after or did you don't
even follow it if you're not following
who's this angle of a GoPro attached to
a helicopter rotor blade it's kind of
funny there's a whole discussion about
whether or not this would imbalance the
blades and like how we went about doing
this I'm here to reveal our secrets a
lot of people thought we actually took a
GoPro strapped to a rotor blade and
turned it on
that's probably impossible the GoPro
would definitely go flying off we used a
little bit of trickery on this shot
here's how we did it helicopters the
main rotor blade is attached to a tail
rotor and if you spin the tail rotor it
spins the main rotor blade there's me
crouch down there watching and then the
guys who own the helicopter slowly
spinning that rotor blade causing the
main rotor blade to spin just bring a
GoPro on with a suction cup mount not a
big deal and spinning the tail rotor
causing the main rotor to spin at a very
slow speed also not a big deal no risk
of damaging anything a very safe shot
however the camera goes very very slowly
what I needed to do is I needed to make
a loop so he recorded the GoPro going
around twice took us two minutes so I
got the clip and I found though in and
out points where it just perfectly lined
up and I looped it I just pasted it over
and over and over and I made a
composition that's over an hour long so
then I took this clip and I sped it up
thousand percent so that our long clip
became six minutes long it looked good
it was spinning fast but I wanted to
give the impression that the helicopter
was turning on the blade of spinning
faster and faster and faster so I used
time work so you can start it off at
100% speed and go up to 200% speed then
go up
a thousand percent speed and I use this
to give myself a speed ramp the
helicopter going faster and faster and
faster now keep in mind this is on top
of the footage already being sped up a
thousand percent which still looks
pretty slow this looked great the
helicopter blades were now moving at the
right speed it felt like they are
turning on however there's a key
ingredient that was missing motion blur
it's not stopping
are you drinking water
yeah that's not helping you that's a bad
idea this was enough water
oh well no I have dried Carolina Reaper
peppers upstairs but the thing is you
don't wanna eat them plain in these
[ __ ] water
you damn plain the spiciness just kind
of like makes you feel sick it's like
dropping like tiny drops of acid into
your stomach motion blur is key to
making things like fast and natural
there's something called optical flow
it's just a general term for plugins
that will track the movement of pixels
in your frames optical flow is also
useful for adding motion blur to the
shot so that's exactly what I did so
time warp has a method called pixel
motion aka optical flow what it's doing
is it's analyzing each frame and the
frames kind of behind it and the frames
in front of it and trying to guess where
pixels are moving and it's applying a
blur then to those pixels and once the
blades start spinning fast enough and
the picture gets chaotic enough the
whole background just turns into a wash
of blur and you can no longer see
anybody on the ladder you can't see
anything in the background
it just becomes a very realistic looking
fast-moving shot that's how I did a
GoPro on the helicopter rotor blade as
it turned on and it kind of creates like
look okay it's like smokes 100 Shelia's
rub my eye to the center
huh I just rubbed my eye weii i actually
watch my hands as soon as possible
dear beat
so it's just the small I put I ate it
with this hand but then I must have at
some point they like done this it's
actually good hmm
I like doing just what I was talking to
Ren and then I got it in my other hand
and I just rolled my eyes this is not
the worst of eyeball spice experience
but it's not my favorite one either
you